con nuestro primer invitado el día vamos
a hablar de la polémica que envuelve al
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
luego de que fueran encontradas cajas
con documentos clasificados en sus
oficinas cuando era vicepresidente de
Barack Obama y de su cascente Delaware
para ello vamos a saludar al doctor
Guillermo Pacheco director Internacional
del Security College en Estados Unidos
Gracias por estar con nosotros doctor
Guillermo esta mañana de lunes en
directo América de Francia 24 y le
pregunto si este caso podría poner en
riesgo legal al presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden Buenos días gusto
saludarte fíjate que creo que ahora como
está la el Capitolio mayoría republicana
en la cámara representantes pero una
mayoría leve de los demócratas en el en
el en el senado Me parece que sí podría
haber un un tratamiento de un pero
siempre no pasaría en el en el senado sí
le van a lo van a llevar a un
impeachment los republicanos
pero en el senado no va a pasar digo
hasta ese momento claro además a
Guillermo hablemos un poco de estasa
comparaciones entre estas revelaciones
de Joe biden que también van a ser
investigadas por un fiscal especial allá
no anunciaron el pasado día jueves y la
que están en curso también por estos
documentos encontrados en la residencia
de Mara Lago del que fuera el presidente
de Estados Unidos Donald Trump
recordemos también toda esta polémica
Entonces qué comparaciones podemos tener
en estos dos casos no Mira a la larga
las comparaciones es que son casos
similares Incluso el mismo biden hace
más o menos tres cuatro meses en una
entrevista que le hicieron el mismo
expresó cómo es posible que eso ocurra
con un expresidente o sea él él puso la
vara al Al mismo nivel Y entonces me
parece que la comparación es que ambos
en ambos casos Si los documentos que se
encuentran son llegados a
determinados que son
no son desclasificados sino que son
clasificados y que ellos no los pueden
tener por muy expresidentes que sean sea
las comparaciones son que ambos casos
están en las mismas circunstancias
Guillermo Cuál es la delicadeza de estos
hallazgos digamos estamos hablando de
secretos de estado de documentos o
clasificados que solamente lo puede
saber el gobierno y el presidente de
turno también llama la atención que ya
son dos expresidentes los que se han
llevado estos documentos como si nada
pasara hay hay algún registro de estos
documentos Cuántos son si lo saca un
presidente tener ese registro para ver
cuándo lo tiene que devolver porque
pareciera por lo que estamos viendo que
no hay ningún tipo de control y
cualquiera se los puede llevar digamos
cualquiera que tenga acceso a ellos Mira
tú te puedes imaginar la cantidad de
documentos que un presidente de Estados
Unidos puede tener en el contexto de
clasificados entonces me parece que el
hecho de contabilizar puede pueden tener
y deberían tener un proceso
Tratamos de tenerlo contabilizados los
presidentes en Estados Unidos no les
pertenece Mientras estén en el gobierno
nada ni las comunicaciones de teléfono
recordemos que Obama fue el primero que
ya pudo tener un teléfono todas esas
conversaciones pertenecen al gobierno
entonces El ejercicio es que yo salgo y
no me puedo llevar nada así un ni una o
solo a hoja que pertenezca al ejercicio
de gobierno Entonces ya sea que sea tan
clasificado digamos que puede afectar la
seguridad misma de los Estados Unidos o
clasificado con no tanta incidencia a la
seguridad de todos modos la ley es la
ley que no pueden llevarse ni una sola
hoja que esté considerada clasificada
sin embargo Esto ocurrió Guillermo
podríamos saber digamos en alguna
oportunidad no sé si más adelante Qué
tipo de documentos o de qué sí Cuáles
secretos A lo mejor estaban en esos
documentos estoy seguro Aquí hay un
proceso que cada cierto tiempo un
desclasificados esos clasificados
entonces
la lo difícil lo comprometido en esto
era que en ninguno de los dos casos eran
documentos ya desclasificados sino a un
clasificados Sí vamos a llegar a saberlo
porque siempre el archivo nacional
provoca estos procesos de desclasificar
Sí vamos a saber no lo vamos a saber si
no han cumplido el tiempo por mucho
hayan sido encontrados en las oficinas
de ambos lo vamos a saber hasta que se
llegue el tiempo Guillermo las
consecuencias A lo mejor que podría
traer la filtración de algunos
documentos que hasta ahora están
clasificados
Bueno mira definitivamente el problema
es que incluso en el caso de biden quien
los encuentra es el abogado mismo o sea
quiere decir que ya hubo otra persona
que que tuvo acceso a esos documentos en
el caso de lo que Se generó de Trump más
mediáticamente fue el mismo FBI el que
el que llegó a la casa entonces se
genera un proceso en el que como no se
sabe el tipo de clasificados que fueron
encontrados
la la duda se mantiene qué tanto
compromete la seguridad de los Estados
Unidos mientras estos sean clasificados
y otras personas hayan tenido acceso a
esos documentos Guillermo esto en su
opinión le merece una investigación una
investigación mayor es decir la olla se
destapó con el presidente con el
expresidente Donald Trump cuando se
encontraron estos documentos después de
dejar la Casa Blanca en su residencia en
la Florida en maralao luego también
ahora Estamos Sabiendo de estos
documentos del presidente actual Joe
biden que se encontraron en una oficina
cuando era vicepresidente bajo el
gobierno de Barack Obama y también en su
casa privada enware pero si esto pasó
con estos últimos presidentes del curso
y el presidente en curso y el pasado
esto pudiera haber pasado con otros
mandatarios que no sabemos hasta el
momento
Mira sin lugar a duda recuerda también
aquí que la ley le permite a las
autoridades poder entrar a las oficinas
que puedan tener los ex presidentes aquí
cada cada expresidente siempre mantiene
una oficina o ya sea antes en su proceso
de elección o o después entonces
evidentemente a la al generarse Dos
procesos se abre un interrogante que
pudieron haberse llevado y obviamente
como tú mencionaste los controles para
saber qué documento le son entregados a
los presidentes va a ser puesto en
estudio para que puedan ellos recibir y
entregar sin quedarse con ningún
documento pero definitivamente va va a
abrir una posibilidad de que se genere
una investigación
esta investigación Guillermo hasta donde
puede llegar es decir cuáles son las
consecuencias o las penas entre comillas
por así decir lo que podría enfrentar o
Donald Trump o Joe biden de ser hallados
digamos culpables también de alguna
manera llevarse estos documentos que no
se podían llevar haber sido encontrados
en sus casas en sus residencias privadas
Mira me parece que en en ambos casos lo
que se va a buscar es una es una pena
también no solo la pena judicial que
pueda darse sin una pena política un
castigo político en el caso de Donald
Trump lo que se estaba buscando es
poderlo encontrar culpable y que él no y
limitarlo a que él no fuera candidato en
estas próximas elecciones del año
entrante eso sería en el caso de Donald
Trump en el caso del presidente biden me
parece que es más comprometido porque al
final él es el presidente actual y que
en dado caso de que este este
investigador especial que ahora ya
nombró el el la cámara de representantes
puedan contar que verdaderamente los
documentos comprometen la seguridad sin
que puedan conocerse pueda generarle un
empeichmen que incluso los mismos
demócratas no puedan defenderlo a él y
puedan destituir al presidente o sea son
dos casos políticamente hablando que van
en en la línea de impedir ya su
continuidad política claro Guillermo ya
rápidamente no
cuánto se puede demorar esta
investigación Y cómo va la de Donald
Trump Mira yo me parece Me parece que
ambas investigaciones van a llevar un
tiempo que va a estar determinado
también dentro de lo político me explico
evidentemente en el caso de Donald Trump
el hecho mismo de limitarlo en la en la
en la carrera presidencial que ya por
decirlo así empezó no con una intensidad
grande pero hacerlo y en el caso del
presidente es igual aguantarlo lo mayor
posible para que cuando salga la luz y
pueda ser un
ya no haya tiempo político para los
demócratas en el mismo caso para poder
nombrar para tener que buscar a alguien
en sustituto en la campaña tenemos que
entender que aún cuando sean el congreso
y Judicial siempre entra el aspecto
político